[Music]
hello to all hello Mr.
Minister so delighted to be among you and
thank you for welcoming us so from
bomb attacks a company which
at the start is specialized in
the image analysis that we have
worked a lot to democratize
image analysis in the public space and therefore
we realized that to be
respected privacy by design in all that is
European rgp d and c it was necessary to
compress the neural networks to
process  images as quickly as
possible we developed a lot of
research we published papers in
europe sas and the icv pma and
implementing them we realized in
fact that these research papers there and
by implementing these technologies we were able
to  compress
other people's neural networks and therefore our purpose
within trust and to bring these
technologies there for actually where everyone is
looking to make it happen we
make it right we really want to
compress networks  of neural networks to
facilitate their deployment on the edge
adapt the weights of the
neural networks to different contexts without
uploading images or sounds or texts
to be able to really in fact succeed in
being the industrial partner in
the deployment on the scale of  these
northern networks once again thank you and
they are dreaming well here
[Applause]
[Music]